dieter is facing criticism from many
nevadans over its recent use of
idme identity verification thanks for
staying with us here at 6 30. i'm denise
valdis and i'm brian loftis this was
recently implemented and the goal of it
was to help avoid fraud
christian casadas joining us now live
with some of the issues this is causing
and also how dieter is responding
that's right guys well we have received
many viewer concerns over this identity
verification which they say is
preventing claimants
from getting their unemployment they say
the phone lines are busy or the website
is just
not working properly now today we spoke
to a las vegas resident andrew wielinski
who says he has been on unemployment
since the beginning of last year
he has navigated through different
issues over the past months but
when dieter implemented their id me
layer of protection
he says it created a big headache other
viewers tell us phone lines are usually
busy or
told to call back later now we reached
out to dieter about the security measure
that was implemented for filers
on the pandemic unemployment assistance
or pua and regular unemployment
insurance claimants that began on july
22nd
they say this helps to verify claimants
and helps eliminate fraud
andrew says while the idea is great the
process is broken
i got the answers of why they're doing
it i understand the fraud is so bad but
i mean it's not fair to people like me i
mean i want to go back to work
but the conventions they're going to be
cancelling a lot of things coming up
if this delta variant goes higher than
they expect
well deter tells us ui claimants need to
validate their identity they say about
88 percent of users
can complete the process while about
only 12 percent need
help they encourage claimants to use
google chrome as a web browser
also if you wish to do this in person
they say you can visit a local library
or a one-stop career center
to use computers with a webcam to help
complete the id
process now remember extended
unemployment insurance benefits they
expire on september 4th
for more information visit our website
eightnewsnow.com christian casadas 8
news now